extraordinary birthdays is an
organization that i created to instill
self-worth and homeless children on
their birthday
when i started you know somebody said
you know it's just a birthday you know i
mean my god they need a house they need
this and like yeah they need to be
recognized too
[Music]
i'm chanel leak and i'm the founder of
extraordinary birthdays we go and
partner with shelters to provide
personalized birthday parties for
homeless children i want every child to
feel like their parents ordered this
party up we're just
the people that are helping to make it
happen
that says unicorn all day long right
it's like super cute since 2010 we have
celebrated over 800 kids i started with
one shelter and in 2011 you know we got
another shelter and we are now up to
nine shelters and that's in dc maryland
and virginia
extraordinary birthdays is not just me
we have our party planners they are the
heart and soul of eob because they are
planning parties for children they don't
know
that is hard to do goodie bags
now that is over the top and they're
putting all of this together from the
plates to the napkins the tablecloths
they are creating the centerpieces all
of this will be part of that efforts we
do into transforming the shelter
[Music]
one of my greatest joys is their first
response when they come in the room
their expectations are so low that when
they come in they just they can't
believe this party
and we've hit it on the head every
single time so we have this
questionnaire that basically has the
children's name their age who's coming
we usually say to them give us three
things on your wish list three things
that they want this is also part of her
gift i didn't bring her other gifts but
i will have them tomorrow
um because they were super huge okay
[Music]
and then we always ask them what kind of
cake
and how awesome is it that we are able
to fill that because that's specifically
what that child wants
[Music]
the people that come to the parties are
other children in the shelter when a
child is homeless they're not inviting
their friends from school their friends
from school don't know they live in a
shelter
their friends are in the shelter so we
really are too about building this
community it's more about the birthday
child but it's about
the culture of those other homeless
children too because they're going away
with goodie bags just like everyone else
and these are things that are speaking
to them in quiet ways even though it's
not their birthday we are still having
some type of impact on that child for
that moment
this mother said
something so profound to me she says
when you are homeless
the system reminds you of that every day
she said my daughter did something
normal today she went to a birthday
party
for that moment
that mom was able to be a mom
so the children get to see their parents
as parents
and not in a line getting food or
you know being part of the handout and
that's what i love because what i wanted
to do
is to take the simple concept of a
birthday party and disrupt everyone's
thinking
[Music]